[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في كل مكان اهلا بكم جميعا الى
حلقه جديده من برنامج من واشنطن حلقه هذا
الاسبوع تاتيكم من مدينه نيويورك حيث جرت
فعاليات اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه التي
نظمتها اليونسكو منظمه الامم المتحده
للتربيه والعلوم والثقافه بمقر الامم
المتحده اهتمام تلك الفعاليات انصب على
مناقشه الجوانب المضيئه في مسيره حريه
الصحافه كاطلاق سراح صحفي الجزيره هشام
عبد العزيز قبل ايام في مصر مثلا ولكن
كذلك الجوانب المظلمه كتواصل الاعتقال
صحفيي الجزيره الاخرين هناك ربيع محمد عبد
الواحد
وبهاء الدين ابراهيم نعمه الله الجوانب
المظلمه تشمل كذلك مقتل صحفيه الجزيره
شيرين ابو عقله برصاصه اسرائيليه لا يزال
من اطلقها يفلت من العقاب حتى الان
اليكم خبر صار
فينا يتعلق بحريه الصحافه
هذا صحفي الجزيره هشام عبد العزيز كان
معتقل بدون محاكمه في مصر
الخبر السار هو انه اطلق سراحه قبل ايام
ولكن لدي خبر سيء كذلك ربيع محمد عبد
الواحد الشيخ صحفي اخر للجزيره لا يزال
معتقل في مصر بدون محاكمه خبر سيء اخر هذا
بهاء الدين ابراهيم نعمه الله صحفي
بالجزيره لا يزال هو ايضا معتقل بدون
محاكمه في مصر ثم
هناك طبعا
قضيه مراسله الجزيره
شيرين ابو عقله التي مضى على مقتلها
برصاصه اسرائيليه عام
ولا تزال العداله لم تتحقق في مقتلها
سنعرض في هذه الحلقه لنماذج من النجاحات
التي تم احرازها على درب حمايه الصحفيين
ولكن ايضا للتحديات التي لا تزال تواجه
العالم في هذا الصدد مراسله الجزيره شيرين
ابو عقله مثلا كانت واحده من عدد كبير من
الصحفيين الذين قتلوا خلال عام 2022
كرغبه
حريه التعبير تعكس حاله مجتمعنا
واذا تراجعت فكافه الحقوق التي ترافقها
تتراجى
مين العام الامم المتحده انطونيو
هو ايضا انه بدون حريه الصحافه لا يمكن ان
تكون هناك حريه في العالم موقف اعرب عنه
كذلك الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال خطابه
في عشاء صحفي البيت الابيض في واشنطن قبل
ايام
الاعلام الحر هو احد اعمده بل هو عمود
مجتمع حر وليس عدوا
قبل ان نعود الى نيويورك وفعاليات اليوم
العالمي لحريه الصحافه نبقى في واشنطن الى
حين حيث اصدر السيناتور الديمقراطي كريس
فان هولن اصدر بيانا هذا الاسبوع دعا فيه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكل الى
نشر التقرير الجديد في مقتل شيرين ابو
عقله التقرير الذي اعده المنسق الامني
الامريكي واضاف فان هولن انه في حين نقترب
من الذكرى الاولى لمقتل شيرين ابو عقله لم
يتم او لم تتم محاسبه احد حتى الان ولم
يستكمل تحقيق مستقل ورسمي
لقد كنا واضحين ومتصقين بشان ادانه القتل
الماساوي لشيرين منذ البدايه وعندما خرج
التقرير الامريكي وكذلك التقرير
الاسرائيلي للعلن الصيف الماضي تحدثنا
باستمرار عن الحاجه والدعوه للمساءله في
هذه القضيه وما زلنا نفعل ذلك وما توصل
اليه الجيش الاسرائيلي وكذلك المنسق
الامني الامريكي فان هذا القتل لم يكن
مقصودا لقد كان حدثا ماساويا بسبب ظروف
ماساويه لذا نعم نواصل السعي لتحقيق
المحاسبه بالنسبه لشيرين
من جهه اخرى كنت قد التقيت النائب
الديمقراطيه رشيده طليب في مقر الكونغرس
حيث تحدثت عن حريه الصحافه مع اقتراب ذكرى
مرور عام على مقتل شيرين ابو عقله
النائبه رشيده طليب شكرا جزيلا على تلبيه
الدعوه ومرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن
بدايه بالنسبه لشيرين ابو عقله طبيعه
الحال شيرين ابو عقله كانت صحفيه انت
نائبه في الكونجرس لكن عدا ذلك انت لديك
شغفك شغف بدورك في الكونغرس كما كان
لشيرين شغف بمهنه الصحافه انت امريكيه
شيرين ابو عقله كانت كذلك امريكيه انت من
اصول فلسطينيه شيرين كانت كذلك من اصول
الفلسطينيه ما الذي تشعرين انه يجمعك
بشيرين في الذكرى الاولى لمقتلها
نقوم بعملنا ونحب القيام به والجميع
يعلمون ان شيرين احبت العمل الصحفي وقول
الحقيقه حول ما يحدث للشعب الفلسطيني سواء
في القدس او في الضفه الغربيه ايضا حيث
تعيش جدتي
وتقول الحقيقه كي توصل الى العالم برمته
صوره انسانيه للفلسطينيين واحاول انا
القيام بشيء نفسه في الكونغرس
كما تتواصل محاولات استهداف وتشويه سمعه
واسكاتي فانا اقول الحقيقه ليس حول عائلتي
واقاربي بل حول كل الاسر التي فقدت احد
افرادها بينما لا تطالب حكومه الولايات
المتحده بمحاسبه اسرائيل عما تقوم به
فاسرائيل لا تخفي ما تقترفه في حق
الفلسطينيين ولا تهتم حتى لو كانوا
هذا امر مقلق جدا لي وبمجرد ان علمت بمقتل
شيرين قبل عام وقفت دقيقه صمت حدادا عليها
كنت احاول ان اذكر بانها بشر لانني كنت
اعرف ما يقوم به الخصوم لقد كانوا يحاولون
تشويه سمعتها كنا بحاجه لذلك النوع من
التعاطف مع قضيتها ومع المطالبه باتخاذ
اجراء مائز مقتلها كنا نعرف حقيقتها منذ
عقود وكانت معروفه لدينا جميعا وكانت
فخوره بعملها واتمنى لو كانت الولايات
المتحده ايضا فخوره بعمل شيرين بحيث تسعى
لتحقيق العداله في قضيه مقتلها فلم يكن
الامر كذلك في حال شيرين وانا اشعر بخيبه
الامل وغاضبه على حكومتنا التي غضت النظر
عما جرى يجب ان تعترف بان اسره شيرين
تواصل زيارات
وتواصل نضالها من اجل تحقيق العداله انها
اسره لا تزال تعاني من صدمه مدمره لما حصل
لحبيبتهم
سنعود للعديد من هذه النقاط التي ذكرتها
الان انما اشرت الى اللحظه التي عندما
سمعت بمقتل شيرين ابو عقله
ودقيقه الصمت في الكونجرس التي دعيتي
اليها في ذلك الوقت هل تشعرين ان تلك
اللحظه عندما وقفت في الكونجرس ودعوتي الى
لحظه صمت وبكيت على مقتل شيرين هل تشعرين
انها غيرت الكثير داخل الكونجرس اولا
قد على رساله طالب فيها بالمحاسبه على
مقتل شيرين ابو عقله لقد كان هذا اكبر عدد
من اعضاء المجلس ممن كافحوا من اجل
فلسطيني او فلسطينيه امريكيه وقالوا ان
خطا جسيما وقع ويجب تصحيحه لقد كانت رساله
قويه وكان الموقعون عليها من خلفيات
متعدده ومن ولايات متعدده ايضا ومنهم
اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ بلغوا العشرين عضوا
وكانوا بقياده السنه الديمقراطي كريسبان
هولن وكما تعلم لم نشهد شيئا من هذا
القبيل قبل ذلك وانا اعمل دوما على
التركيز على البعد الانساني في القضيه
الفلسطينيه والشعب الفلسطيني
ولم تكن شيرين صحفيه فقط بل كانت ايضا
امريكيه وابنه واختا وعمه وقد دخلت بيوت
الجميع عبر التلفزيون ونشانا نعرفها ونعرف
انها كانت دوما في مواقع الحدث
لقد حصل بعض التغيير وما اعجبني هو
ذهول زملائي هنا في الكونغرس تماما كما
ذهلت انا ايضا من مقتلها
[موسيقى]
وقال العشرات منهم انها تستحق العداله لقد
كانت تلك لحظه عظيمه في تاريخ بلادنا
لقد كانت شيرين في حياتها ملهمه وقد دفعت
الكثيرين من زملائي في الكونجرس الى
المطالبه بالمحاسبه عن قتلها وان تاخذ
العداله مجراها ابو عقله
كما تعرفين قبل عشرين ثلاثين
بالتاكيد اربعين سنه كان من الصعب ان لم
يكن من المستحيل ان يسمع صوت عربي صوت
فلسطيني في واشنطن في ذلك الوقت الان هناك
صوت عربي هناك صوت فلسطيني داخل اروقه
الكونغرس داخل اوساط
يتحدث عن ليس فقط قضيه فلسطين قضيه شيرين
ابو عقلاء تحديدا هل عقد باي شكل من
الاشكال مقتل شيرين ابو عقله وجود وجودك
انت في الكونجرس
لا اعتقد ان ذلك قد ادى الى تعقيد موقف
المدافع عن الحقوق الفلسطينيه في الكونجرس
اعتقد ان الامريكيين اليوم يرون نتيجه
المساعدات الهائله التي تقدمها الولايات
المتحده دون قيود مبلغ اربعه مليارات
دولار تقريبا سنويا تقدم لدوله تعتبرها
ثلاث منظمات لحقوق الانسان دوله فصل عنصري
لقد تبين للعالم ان لا احد في مامن هناك
للاطفال ولا الشيوخ
لقد رايت رجلا مسنا ربما كان في السبعينات
من عمره عندما تم قتله ويرى الناس اليوم
ان هذا نظام يمارس العنف ويجب ان تتم
محاسبته وان يحترم حقوق الانسان وان لا
يذهب قتله للامريكيين دون حساب
انت بطبيعه الحال معظم ناخي بك من السود
في المنطقه التي تمثلينها في الكونغرس
سمعنا اصوات من خلفيات اخرى حتى من اليهود
الامريكيين بطبيعه الحال في مقتل شيرين
ابو عقله في الدعوه الى التحقيق في مقتل
شيرين ابو عقله الى غير ذلك يعني من جهه
اخرى
على سؤالي السابق الى اي مدى
ساعد ان امكن انجازات التعبير مقتل شيرين
ابو عقله على بناء جسور بينك انت وبين كل
هذه الفئات الاخرى في المجتمع الامريكي
بمن فيهم اليهود الامريكي
ين
نعملي دوما لفئات المجتمع الامريكي فانا
اطالب دوما بالماء كواحد من حقوق الانسان
هنا في ديترويت وفي غزه ايضا ان قطع الماء
عن البشر هو من اعمال العنف وهو يحدث في
ديترويت حيث ولدت وترعرعت كما يحدث في غزه
ان الظلم والقمع الذي يمارس على
الفلسطينيين تحت الفصل العنصري يقترن
بالظلم الذي يلحق بسكان ديترويت الذين
يعانون من مشكله المياه ويعيشون في ظل
شركات كبرى تلوث مصادر المياه هناك انهم
يستحقون الكرامه الانسانيه والحمايه من
شركات تختن على حساب سلامتهم
ظلم بصرف النظر عن من يمارسه انني اول
فلسطينيه امريكيه تصل الى الكونجرس والذين
انتخبوني ليسوا من خلفيه العرقيه او
الدينيه وكان انتخابي عاده تاريخيا بحد
ذاته ولكنهم لم ينتخبونني لاصنع لقد
انتخبوني لانهم علموا ما خبرته في حياتي
وهو ما يسمح لي بان اقول الحقيقه دائما
حتى لو ارتعش صوتي
في فلسطين ولا ينظرون اليك كممثلتهم في
الكونغرس فحسب بل ايضا كحفيده لجاده
فلسطينيه تعيش في نظام فصل عنصري في
اسرائيل اليوم وهذا مؤلم حقا لان جدتي
ولدت فلسطينيه فهي محرومه من حوريه الحركه
ومن الرعايه الصحيه المطلوبه
لقد علمتني تجربتي في ديترويت ما يلي
عندما نسكت عن الظلم فانه يزداد انتشارا
ولذا فساستمر في التحدث والكلام وساستمر
في النضال من اجل الحقيقه مهما كان لذلك
من عواقب بصرف النظر عما اذا كان الشخص
طفل في غزه او
ما يهمني هو ان يشعران بان صوتهما يسمع
وبان لهما من يدافع عنه
على اننا الاخر واعتبار اننا لا نستحق نفس
الدرجه من الكرامه لمجرد اننا ولدنا
فلسطينيين او سودا او لاننا من ديانه
معينه او لاننا فقراء هو ما يربطنا جميعا
برفض الظلم في كل مكان
عوده الى الذكرى الاولى الان لمقتل شيرين
ابو عقله يعني تقريبا عام مر على مقتل
شيرين ابو عقله ما هو تقييمك لما اقدمت
عليه من خطوات اداره الرئيس جو بايد
لتحقيق العداله لشيرين ابو عقله كما قلت
في مطلع المقابله
ان اداره بايدا لم تقم بما فيه الكفايه بل
هي بعيده عن ذلك الهدف فهناك بلد لا يزال
يمارس العنف والقمعه ضد الفلسطينيين حتى
لو كانوا مواطنين امريكيين ان التمييز ضد
الفلسطينيين الامريكيين عند نقاط العبور
الى اسرائيل صارخ
ليس هناك مكتب فلسطيني في واشنطن يمثل
الفلسطينيين ومكتبي يعمل كانه مكتب لهم
واسمع شكاوى من فلسطينيين امريكيين يقولون
ان الاسرائيليين لا يسمحون لهم بالدخول
لزياره اهاليهم وليس هناك احد في وزاره
الخارجيه يقول كفى من التمييز ضد
الفلسطينيين الامريكيين وان الوزاره لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي
ما حدث في قضيه شيرين هو انهم يامولون ان
ننسى ولكننا لم ننسى ونعرف لم تكن اخر
مواطن امريكي يقتله الاسرائيليون لقد
ازداد انتشار العنف والعنصريه في دوله
الفصل العنصري بسبب عدم مساءلتها من
الجانب الامريكي علينا ان نستخدم ما لدينا
من نفوذ واذا كان الاسرائيليون يرغبون في
الحصول على مساعدات امريكيه من اموال
دافعي الضرائب فيجب ان يتوقفوا عن ممارسه
التمييز وليس الفلسطينيون وحدهم الذين
يتعرضون للتمييز فهناك امريكيون يمنعون من
زياره الاماكن المقدسه ولا يزال عدم
المساءله من قبل اداره بايدن متواصلا لقد
كان امام اداره بايدن فرصه عظيمه اولا
للدفاع عن حريه الصحافه وسلامه الصحفيين
وهو امر هام جدا فلطالما قالت انها تريد
ان تؤمن الطريقه للحقيقه وتحمي
الديمقراطيه
ثانيا كان هناك فرصه عظيمه لتحقيق العداله
لمواطنه امريكيه لديها اسره هنا وياتي
افراد منها من الخارج ايضا وهم يظرفون
الدموع ويطلبون من الاداره ان تتخذ اجراء
ما لتحقيق العداله لشيرين لا اريد ان تحل
الذكرى الثانيه لمقتل شيرين ابو عاقله
وانا اقول ان اداره بايدن لم تقم باي شيء
في هذه القضيه كما امل ان تذكي دعوه
زملائي في الكونجرس الذين وقعوا على رسائل
الى الاداره امل ان تذكر دعوتهم اهتمامها
وان يتاكدوا من انها ستعمل على منع اي
صحفي اخر وان تجنب الاسره نفس المصير
والمعاناه الشديده التي عاشتها اسره شيرين
على يد دوله مموله من ضرائب الامريكيين
وقد وصل الامر بالولايات المتحده لمرحله
فقدان المص في اعين العالم اذا لم تقم
بواجب المحاسبه على قتل شيرين ابو عاقله
بان تقول ان هذا امر غير مقبول وانها لن
تسمح باستهداف الامريكيين ولا بقتل
الصحفيين فحاله شيرين ليست الوحيده هنا
فنحن نرى العنفه الذي يمارس ضد الصحفيين
من قبل اسرائيل ونرى منعهم من الوصول الى
المناطق الفلسطينيه لنقل ما يحصل
للفلسطينيين هناك
شكرا جزيلا
كانت تلك النائبه الديمقراطيه رشيده طليب
في مقر الكونجرس
عوده الان الى نيويورك حيث كان مقتل شيرين
ابو عقله حاضر في فعاليه اليونسكو بمناسبه
اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه في نيويورك
وقد عرضت الجزيره فيلمها الاستقصائي مقتل
شيرين ابو عقله الفائز بجائزه جورج بولك
المرموقه عرضته الجزيره خلال فعاليات
اليونسكو بمقر الامم المتحده كل الشكر
للبعثه الايرلنديه لدى الامم المتحده
على كل ما قدمته في اطار عملها هنا في
الولايات المتحده في ملف مقتل شيرين ابو
عقله منذ اللحظه التي
اذيع فيها نبا مقتل شيرين قبل عام تقريبا
من الان وحتى هذه اللحظه فهذه الغرفه حيث
نجلس الان تم حجزها للجزيره لعرض هذا
الفيلم من قبل البعثه الايرلنديه لدى
الامم المتحده مشكوره الفيلم قدم دلائل
على ان شيرين تعرضت للقتل العمد برصاصه
اسرائيليه وبينما قدمت اسرائيل عده سرديات
متناقضه لقتل شيرين اعربت الخارجيه
الامريكيه في الفيلم عن عدم اعتقادها بان
شيرين قد تعرضت للقتل العمد
كان ناطقا باسم الخارجيه عندما انتج فيلم
قتل شيرين ابو عقله
بالطبع يقلقنا الدعاء ان مدني استهدف عمدا
ما توصل اليه الاسرائيليون والمنسق
الامريكي ايضا هو انه لا يبدو ان هناك
تعمد منسقنا الامني لم يجد اسبابا ليعتقد
ان شيرين ابو عاقله استهدفت عمدا من قبل
الاسرائيليين من ضمن من شاركوا في فعاليات
اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه ايرين خان
المقرره الدوليه الخاصه لحريه التعبير
والراي كيف تقيمين الجهود التي بذلت دوليا
حتى الان لتحقيق العداله لشرين ابو عقله
وحاله شيرين توضح ذلك فقط قتلت وهي ترتدي
ستره كتب عليها صحافه نحن هنا اليوم
للاحتفال باليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه
لذلك نظمت اليونسكو هذا المؤتمر المهم لكن
المؤتمرات لا توفر حلا للمشكله واعتقد ان
هناك حاجه الى اتخاذ اجراءات قويه على
الارض للضغط على اسرائيل والتاكد من تحقيق
العداله واذا لم يكن من الممكن القيام
بذلك على المستوى الوطني اذا فليكن على
المستوى الدولي في الحقيقه لقد دعوت
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
الذي كما تعلمون يعمل الان على قضايا قتل
الصحفيين في اوكرانيا وقلت له لا تنسى
فلسطين ولا تنسى شيرين
يعني هذه الهيئات الدوليه مثل الهيئه التي
ذكرتها الان محكمه الجنايات الدوليه مثلا
يعني ما هو العائق بتصورك انت لقيامها بما
تريدين انت ان تقوم بها هذه الهيئات في
حاله مقتل شيرين ابو عقله
ودام السياسي والرغبه السياسيه هذه هي
المشكله شهد العام الماضي مقتل 86 صحفيا
حول العالم بما في ذلك العديد من الصحفيين
في مناطق النزاع كانت شيرين احداهم
86% من حالات قتل الصحفيين حتى يومنا هذا
لم يجري التحقيق فيها او احالتها على
القضاء لذلك هناك العديد من الحالات مثل
شيرين حيث لا عداله للصحفيين وهذه بالطبع
ماساه لعائله الشخص المعني انها ماساه
واعتقد ان هذا يشكل تهديدا خطيرا للغايه
لوسائل الاعلام المستقله والحره والتعدديه
في العالم نعلم جميعا مدى اهميه الاعلام
للديمقراطيه والتنميه لذا فان الفشل في
التحقيق في قضيه شيرين يعد بمنزله ضربه
لحقوق الانسان والديمقراطيه والتنميه
في حاله شيرين ابو عقله تحديدا وفيما
يتعلق بما تفضلت به الان بالنسبه لتوعيه
الناس بمساله قتل الصحفيين والافلات من
العقاب الى غير ذلك يعني بالنسبه لك انت
كمقرره خاصه للامم المتحده لحريه التعبير
والراي ماذا تعتزيمين القيام به في
المستقبل للاسهام في هذه التوعيه هذه
القضايا اهميه التحقيق العداله للصحفيين
اما اهميه منع قتلهم واهميه محاسبه
المسؤولين عن قتلهم
اولا النطق القضيه ذائعه في الاخبار وانت
تعلم كونك صحفيا ان اهتمام الاخباري يتغير
بسرعه ولذلك فان الفرص مثل هذه هي التي من
خلالها نستمر في التذكير لان قضيتها لا
تزال دون حل وان العداله لم تتحقق بعد في
مقتل شيرين ويجب ان نواصل التذكير بذلك ان
نلفت الانتباه طوال الوقت الى حالتها
والحالات المماثله هذا العام تحل ذكرى 30
لانشاء هذا المنصب الذي اشغله في الامم
المتحده وانا اغتنم هذه الفرصه للفت
الانتباه الى اولئك الذين يناضلون من اجل
حق الانسان في حريه التعبير من يناضل في
الخطوط الاماميه انهم الصحفيون لانهم
يلفتون الانتباه الى حالات مثل شيرين
ويقولون انه عندما ندافع عن حريه الاعلام
فاننا في الواقع ندافع عن انفسنا العام
المقبل سيشهد اربع وعشرين عمليه انتخابيه
حول العالم وسوف ينتشر الصحفيون هناك
لتغطيتها وسيستهدفون هناك نزاعات مستمره
في العديد من الاماكن انظر الى الوضع في
الشرق الاوسط وفي اوكرانيا وفي اجزاء من
افريقيا
الصحفيون يستهدفون هناك ولهذا اذا اردنا
السلام والاستقرار فلا بد من الحفاظ على
حريه نشر المعلومات وان نواصل من اجل هذا
ينبغي ان نبقي على هذه القضايا في العلن
وان نبقي الصحفيين تحت الضوء وان نواصل
التذكير بقضيه شيرين انا استغل اي فرصه
تواتيني لاثير قضيه شيرين كمثال على الخطا
الذي حدث في نظام حقوق الانسان الدولي
والى اننا بحاجه الى عمل المزيد نحن بحاجه
الى انشاء فريق عمل دولي واليه تحقيق
دوليه بحيث عندما لا تستجيب الدول على
المستوى الوطني ولا تحقق بشكل سليم ولا
بطريقه تكون محل الثقه العامه في حاله
شيرين ستقول اسرائيل انها اجرت تحقيقات
متعدده لكن لا توجد ثقه عامه في ان ذلك
جرى بشكل سليم نحن بحاجه الى بعض
الاجتماعات الدوليه لبحث مثل هذه المواقف
شكرا جزيلا
كيف تقيمين الجهود التي بذلت دوليا حتى
الان لتحقيق العداله لشيرين ابو عقله
اعتقد انه امر مشين للغايه ان يحدث ما حدث
لصحفيه مثل شيرين لقد كانت مميزه بشكل خاص
بسبب معرفتها والتزامها وبسبب النموذج
الذي قدمته للصحفيات ليس في المنطقه فحسب
بل حول العالم يجب الا يمر قتل هادون
العداله الملائمه
يؤسفني القول انه عندما يتعلق الامر بحريه
الاعلام فان سلامه الصحافيين امر بالغ
الاهميه الا ان هناك افتقارا الى رغبه
المجتمع الدولي او الحكومات لحمايه
الصحفيين
وحاله شيرين توضح ذلك فقط قتلت وهي ترتدي
ستره كتب عليها صحافه نحن هنا اليوم
للاحتفال باليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه
لذلك نظمت اليونسكو هذا المؤتمر المهم لكن
المؤتمرات لا توفر حلا للمشكله
واعتقد ان هناك حاجه الى اتخاذ اجراءات
قويه على الارض للضغط على اسرائيل والتاكد
من تحقيق العداله واذا لم يكن من الممكن
القيام بذلك على المستوى الوطني اذا فليكن
على المستوى الدولي بالحقيقه لقد دعوت
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
الذي كما تعلمون يعمل الان على قضايا قتل
الصحفيين في اوكرانيا وقلت له لا تنسى
فلسطين ولا تنسى شيرين
يعني هذه الهيئات الدوليه مثل الهيئه التي
ذكرتها الان محكمه الجنايات الدوليه مثلا
يعني ما هو العائق بتصورك انت لقيامها بما
تريدين انت ان تقوم بها هذه الهيئات في
حاله مقتل شيرين ابو عقله
السياسي والرغبه السياسيه هذه هي المشكله
شهد العام الماضي مقتل 86 صحفيا حول
العالم بما في ذلك العديد من الصحفيين في
مناطق النزاع كانت شيرين احداهم
86% من حالات قتل الصحفيين حتى يومنا هذا
لم يجري التحقيق فيها او احالتها على
القضاء لذلك هناك العديد من الحالات مثل
شيرين حيث لا عداله للصحفيين وهذه بالطبع
ماساه لعائله الشخص المعني انها ماساه
واعتقد ان هذا يشكل تهديدا خطيرا للغايه
لوسائل الاعلام المستقله والحره والتعدديه
في العالم نعلم جميعا مدى اهميه الاعلام
للديمقراطيه والتنميه لذا فان الفشل في
التحقيق في قضيه شيرين يعد بمنزله ضربه
لحقوق الانسان وللديمقراطيه والتنميه
في حاله شيرين ابو عقله تحديدا وفيما بما
تفضلت به الان بالنسبه لتوعيه الناس
بمساله قتل الصحفيين والافلات من العقاب
الى غير ذلك يعني بالنسبه لك انت كمقرره
خاصه للامم المتحده لحريه التعبير والراي
ماذا تعتزيمين القيام به في المستقبل
للاسهام في هذه التوعيه بهذه القضايا
اهميه التحقيق العداله للصحفيين اما اهميه
منع قتلهم واهميه محاسبه المسؤولين عن
قتلهم
اولا ان نبقي القضيه ذائعه في الاخبار
وانت تعلم كونك صحفيا ان اهتمام الاخباريه
بسرعه ولذلك فان الفرص مثل هذه هي التي من
خلالها نستمر في التذكير بان قضيتها لا
تزال دون حل وان العداله لم تتحقق بعد في
مقتل شيرين ويجب ان نواصل التذكير بذلك
وان نلفت الانتباه طوال الوقت الى حالتها
والحالات المماثله هذا حلو وذكرى الثلاثون
لانشاء هذا المنصب الذي اشغله في الامم
المتحده وانا اختنم هذه الفرصه للفت
الانتباه الى اولئك الذين يناضلون من اجل
حق الانسان في حريه التعبير من يناضل في
الخطوط الاماميه انهم الصحفيون لانهم
يلفتون الانتباه الى حالات مثل شيرين
ويقولون انه عندما ندافع عن حريه الاعلام
فاننا في الواقع ندافع عن انفسنا العام
المقبل سيشهد 24 عمليه انتخابيه حول
العالم وسوف ينتشر الصحفيون هناك لتغطيتها
وسيستهدفون هناك نزاعات مستمره في العديد
من الاماكن انظر الى الوضع في الشرق
الاوسط وفي اوكرانيا وفي اجزاء من افريقيا
الصحفيون يستهدفون هناك ولهذا اذا اردنا
السلام والاستقرار فلا بد من الحفاظ على
حريه نشر المعلومات وان نواصل الكفاح من
اجل هذا ينبغي ان نبقي على هذه القضايا في
العالم
هي الصحفيين تحت الضوء وان نواصل التذكير
بقضيه شيرين انا استغل اي فرصه تواتيني
لاثير قضيه شيرين كمثال على الخطا الذي
حدث في نظام حقوق الانسان الدولي والى
اننا بحاجه الى عمل المزيد نحن بحاجه الى
انشاء فريق عمل دولي واليه تحقيق دوليه
بحيث عندما لا تستجيب الدول على المستوى
الوطني ولا تحقق بشكل سليم ولا بطريقه
تكون محل الثقه العامه في حاله شيرين
ستقول اسرائيل انها اجرت تحقيقات متعدده
لكن لا توجد ثقه عامه في ان ذلك جرى بشكل
سليم نحن بحاجه الى بعض الاجتماعات
الدوليه لبحث مثل هذه المواقف
شكرا جزيلا
مقاس الصحفيين لا تنحصر في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط طبعا او في اي منطقه بعينها من
العالم ايفان غورس مراسل صحيفه وستريد
جيرمن مثلا اعتقلته السلطات الروسيه في
التاسع والعشرين من شهر مارس الماضي
واتهمته بالتجسس لصالح الولايات المتحده
اتهام نفته بشده اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
الذي اكد التزامه بالعمل على عوده غورس
كوفيتش الى الولايات المتحده حرا طليقا
وقد قابلت ناشر الصحيفه المار لاتور ضمن
فعاليات اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه
يسعدني ان اجري هذا الحوار عن ايفان
جورسكوفيتش مراسل صحيفه الولسري جيرمن
المعتقل حاليا في روسيا مع ناشر الصحيفه
المار لتور
ولكن قبل ان ابدا هذا الحوار
اليكم خبر سار
فيما يتعلق بحريه الصحافه
هذا صحفي الجزيره هشام عبد العزيز كان
معتقل بدون محاكمه في مصر
الخبر السار هو انه اطلق سراحه قبل ايام
ولكن لدي خبر سيء كذلك ربيع محمد عبد
الواحد الشيخ صحفي اخر للجزيره لا يزال
معتقل في مصر بدون محاكمه
خبر سيء اخر هذا بهاء الدين ابراهيم نعمه
الله صحفي للجزيره لا يزال هو ايضا معتقل
بدون محاكمه في مصر ثم
هناك طبعا قضيه مراسله الجزيره
شيرين ابو عقله التي مضى على مقتلها
برصاصه اسرائيليه عام
ولا تزال العداله لم تتحقق في مقتلها
للاسف هذه ليست نهايه الاخبار السيئه
هذه صوره
للصفحه الرئيسيه لصحيفه
اليوم 31 مارس الماضي
عنوانها يقول اذا
احب روسيا التي انقلبت عليه
وسيكون ذلك مدخلي للحوار معك المار نتور
حدثنا عن ما جاء في العنوان وذكر بقضيه
ايفان ماذا حدث هو
اولا شكرا جزيلا على لفت الانتباه الى هذه
القضيه والى حريه الصحافه حول العالم
ايفان هو مراسل لولو من العمر واحدا وهو
كاتب عظيم
ولديه التزام عميق وشغف بموضوع عمله
كان ابواه لاجئين اتيا الى الولايات
المتحده من الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق وكان
ايفان شغوفا بمعرفه روسيا والتعمق في
شؤونها بحيث يتمكن من روايه قصص حول
جمالها وكذلك التحديات التي تواجهها
وقد فعل ذلك بشكل رائع عن طريق القصص
المذهله التي كتبها لكن اثناء عمله كصحفي
معتمد في روسيا تم اعتقاله واتهامه زورا
بالتجسس تم كل ذلك في لحظه لم نتمكن من
رؤيته الا عن طريق تسجيل مصور وكان يجلس
في قفص زجاجي خلال جلسه استماع وهو الان
محتجز منذ اكثر من اربعه اسابيع
الاجراءات المتبعه حتى مع اتهام ايفان
بالتجسس ظلما تم خرقها وتم تاجيلها وتضييق
محاوله التواصل معه ولكن عرفنا من خلال
الرسائل ومن خلال الدعم الدولي الذي انهال
عليه انه يتلقى الكثير من المسانده وهو
يتمكن من قراءه الرسائل من خلال المحامين
الروس الذين يتولون الدفاع عنه
وهو لا يستطيع ان يخبرنا اي شيء يتعلق
بقضيته ولكن سمعنا من المحامين ان ايفان
ممتن وانه يقرا الرسائل التي تصل اليه
كيف حال اسرته
بقضاء بعض الوقت مع عائله ايفان الاسبوع
الماضي ومره اخرى خلال نهايه الاسبوع
الجاري في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
وهم صامدون بطريقه ملهمه والدته الى تقضي
وقتها في تقصي اخر تطورات القضيه والتفكير
في حلول لتامين اطلاق سراحك
اما والده ميكيل فهو صامد ايضا وكذلك
شقيقته دانيلا وزوجها انفيني
[موسيقى]
وراء هذا الهدف وبالطبع الامر مفعم
بالعواطف ويتخلله الم عميق ان ترى شخصا
تحبه يعتقل بتهم باطله خلال ادائه لعمله
لكن الاسره قويه وهذا ما لمسته خلال نهايه
الاسبوع في واشنطن حيث ساهمنا في تواصلهم
مع الرئيس جو بايدن في اجتماع شخصيتي
كيف تقيم منظمه اليونسكو اوضاع حريه
الصحافه وسلامه الصحفيين في العالم منذ
قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده تخصيص
يوم عالمي لحريه الصحافه قبل ثلاثين عاما
الدكتور توفيق جيلاسي مساعد المدير العامه
لليونسكو للتواصل والاعلام في حديث خاص مع
برنامج من واشنطن على هامش اليوم العالمي
لحريه الصحافه دكتور جلاسيه مرحبا بك في
برنامج من واشنطن شكرا على تلبيه الدعوه
اود في البدايه ان اسالك سمعنا من الامين
العاملي الامم المتحده يتحدث عن حريه
الصحافه يقول ليس هناك حريه بدون حريه
الصحافه سمعنا من الرئيس الامريكي الكلام
مشابه جو بايدن سمعنا بعض الاحصائيات من
المدير العامه لليونسكو
صحفي قتلوا خلال عام 2022
يعني كيف يمكن التوفيق بين هذين المعطيين
من جهه هناك اعتراف باهميه حريه الصحافه
من جهه ثانيه هناك ارقام مرعبه لقتل
الصحفيين
الارقام هي مرعبه لان الاحصائيه التي
ذكرتموها هي عدد الصحافيين الذين قتلوا
بسبب عملهم اثناء القيام بمهمتهم خارج
الاعلام وصحافيين رقم السنه الماضيه هو
رقم مخيف لانه هو في في صعود بالنسبه
للسنه التي
سنه 2021
ايضا احصائيات اليونسكو تظهر انه 83%
من الذين ساهموا في حاله دراسيه اليونسكو
هم يعبروا على تراجع حريه الصحافه وحريه
التعبير في بلدانهم 83% هذا ايضا شيئا
مخيف
هو صار وعي لكن ايضا موضوع حريه التعبير
يهم عده جهات معنيه
السلطات بطبيعه الحال وايضا المجتمع
المدني وايضا شركات التكنولوجيا التي هي
تقوم
باداره المنصات الرقميه فهو ضروري يكون
معناتها تكاثف وجهود الجميع
لمكافحه هذا الشيء المخيف وايضا
لتقويه وضمان حريه الصحافه كما قلت لانه
هو حق من حقوق الانسان وهو قاطره
للحقوق الانسان الاخرى خلال 30 سنه التي
يحتفل بها
يحتفل فيها العالم بالي وم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه ما هي الانجازات التي يمكن ان
يشار اليها في مجال مكافحه الافلات من
العقاب
هذا السؤال الهام جدا هنا صار بعض التقدم
له تقدم غير كافي لما نرجع احصائيات
الماضيه كانت نسبه الافلات من على الانقاب
لجرائم قتل الصحفين اكثر من 90% السنه
الماضيه نزلت الى 83%
فصار تحصن نسبي لكن من حالات قتل
الصحافيين لم تتم المتابعه القضائيه
بكاملها بالنسبه المتهمين بارتكاب هذه
الجرائم هذا ما قمنا به شهر 11 الماضي شهر
نوفمبر في ندوه
وزاريه في فيينا بالنمسا
للحديث وتقييم
عشر سنوات من منظمه عمل الامم المتحده
لمكافحه الافلات من العقاب ضد جرائم
الصحفيين وهذا العمل للامم المتحده هو
انبثق من اليونسكو منذ عشره سنوات دخلت
فصار تقدم لكن تقدم نسبي وليس كافي يعني
بالنسبه
للفاعلين كما تفضلت هناك حكومات هناك
مجتمع مدني الى غير ذلك يعني اين بؤره
الالتقاء في تصور اليونسكو اين البؤره
التي يجب ان تلتقي فيها الاعمال من كل
هؤلاء الفاعلين لمكافحه الافلات من العقاب
احنا الجناس والسنه الماضيه بدات مبادره
اهمه دوليه وهو
تطوير او صياغه مبادئ
توجيهيه لتنظيم عمل المنصات الرقميه لكي
تصبح المعلومات ذات منفعه عامه لان الان
المعلومات كما تحدثنا على المنصات الرقميه
في عدد الحالات هي مضره عامه او هي سبب
خطر دهم على الافراد على المجتمعات
فاحنا قمنا بالمبادره هذه اللي هي متعدده
الاطراف نرجع للسؤال متاعك 193 دوله
عضوه في اليونسكو والامم المتحده المشاركه
فيها الشركات الرقميه التي هي تدير
الملفات الرقميه المشاركه فيها منظمات
المجتمع المدني العالم الاكاديمي فهو
ضروري انه جميعا نلتف حول صياغه مبادئ
توجيهيه لتنظيم عمل النشاط الرقميه هذا
مثلا من الاجابات او الحلول للتحدي الرقمي
اللي هو
اصبح اليوم بعتها المكان الاول للقارئ
للمجتمع للبحث عن المعلومه استعمال هذه
المنصات نهايه يعني اليوم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه العام المقبل
سيعقد في تشيلي تشيلي طبعا معروفه
بتاريخها السياسي كانت ديكتاتوريه تعرضت
فيها الصحفي لكثير من الماسي لكن شيء
ليموند ذلك الوقت بطبيعه الحال حق التقدم
على طريق الحكم المدني والديمقراطيه يعني
ما الدلاله التي يجب ان يستشفها العالم من
تنظيم هذا المؤتمر في دوله كتشيلي
اظن في السماء بين همين هنا هو صحيح تاريخ
تشيلي
القديم والحاضر في التشيلي لهذا بلد قام
بنقله نوعيه
لاحترام حريه التعبير وحريه الصحافه
ودعمها فليونسكوب بقبول دعوه تشيلي
لاستضافه المؤتمر العالمي لحرد صحافه هو
دلاله اليونسكو هي تساهم في تطوير التقدم
الذي قام به هذا برد الدلاله الثانيه
او البلدان في العالم في قتل الصحفيين هي
امريكا الجنوبيه وامريكا الوسطى احنا باش
نروح لامريكا لهذا لهذا لهذه الجهه لتركيز
الضوء على هذه الحالات التي لا يمكن ان
نقبلها فنحن نسلط الاضواء على جهه يجب ان
تحترم اكثر بكثير حريه الصحافه حريه
التعبير
وممارسه الصحافيين ورجال الاعمال ونساء
الاعمال لعملهم بكل حريه شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا
شكرا جزيلا بارك الله فيك كان ذلك الدكتور
توفيق جيلاسي مساعده المديره العامه
لليونسكو للتواصل والاعلام في حديث خاص مع
برنامج من واشنطن على هامش اليوم العالمي
لحريه الصحافه
بمقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
انتهت الحلقه يمكنكم التواصل معنا
كالمعتاد عبر بريدنا الالكتروني وفيسبوك
وتويتر حلقه هذا الاسبوع واكبت فعاليات
اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه في مقر الامم
المتحده تحيه لكم جميعا اينما كنتم من هذا
الموقع على ضفه نهر عدسون المطله على
مقاطعه من هاتن في نيويورك المدينه التي
لا تعرف النوم كما يقال حتى في الليل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]